so I'm going to be talking about sort of
Education analytics in or from language
but I'm also going to be talking about
data set and so on so let's see here so
first okay so first just sort of a quick
introduction to those not really
familiar with with data set so for those
who don't know data set is basically
just a nice way of representing like
nested structures of of lists and
associations primarily so if I have so
for example given this the structure of
listen associations here i can say data
set of that and it will make me this
nice data set so what are the advantages
of using a data set so first of all when
you when you query a data set you can do
many of the sort of similar things you
can do with part so if I have this list
L right and I i can say something part
take 2 comma you know a and that will
get me the 8th index of the second or
the eighth key of the second indexed
thing in L so I can do the same thing
with this data set so if I have this
data set d I can say that of 2 comma a
and now that will do the same thing so
so you can see you sort of have this
same structure where you where you
basically specify what you want from
each level as you as you go down but now
the cool thing about data set is that it
lets you also apply functions and so on
so it lets you apply functions at weird
levels inside of these inside of these
structures so for example if i said
something idea of to write that's just
going to be this this second second row
here but i could say something d of 2
comma F and you can see that applies f
to that second row I could also maybe
say something like D of D of F comma 2
which will apply F to let me see what is
that doing or sorry DMF coming come a
which will apply F to all of the 8th
indices so that's pretty useful in this
case though we could still do this
fairly easily with a list we could say
something like L part 0 comma
a and maybe just say f of that but even
still this is slightly nicer and we're
going to get cases where where to use
part would be just vastly less efficient
in terms of both speeding good oo this
scale yes yes yes you see is that better
for a bit bigger is that good okay
that's good great okay so so it's that's
just sort of the or okay actually won
one other quick thing about about data
set here so if we look at the other
thing is that lets say we want to apply
you know multiple functions at a certain
level so for example if I go back to
that example right D of F come a let's
say I also want to apply G some other
function that does something else sort
of you do the logical thing which is
that you can use a composition so i can
run something like this which okay so
for those who don't know because this is
a somewhat new in fix i think this is
version 10 this is the in fix for right
composition so basically let's see f
right composed with G of X is the same
as G of f of X so what the what the
point of this is it's exactly the same
as composed except the order is flipped
and sort of the logic of this is just
that it reads sort of like like English
text from left to right so it's when you
have big strings to these things it can
often be a bit a bit more legible but so
you can the point is that I can you can
put in a compose into this and you know
it works just like you'd expect it to
accept actually as we'll see in a moment
with data set it doesn't really treat
this as a single composed function you
can actually deal with it so for example
let's say I have a data set let's say we
go back to that example or I said to
come eh I can actually write something
like that ok what that's doing is it see
it's it's getting to a and that's
applying app so it's basically it's
getting the the eighth index of the
second element and that's applying f at
sort of the first level so now you'll
notice though that this here is not
really a function on composing the
number
to with some function f for some symbol
F so that doesn't inherently really make
much sense so the point is that data set
treats these compositions less as actual
functions less as actual compositions
and more as sort of a series of things
which it should apply in some ways you
can you can also think about it is for
example you could say this this to this
index is more of just a function that
will you can think of it more as
representing a function that will get
say the second index but all right so
let's let's move on to some more sort of
interest in case so I'm going to be
basically what I'm going to be doing
here is I'm going to be playing around
with this education data and trying to
show some sort of basically try and show
some of the more interesting uses of
data set but this is sort of the data on
which to use it so let me see so if i
run this here this should get me my my
anonymized data so let's try something
very simple so sorry one of the data
sets I have a bunch of data sets here so
I can I can look at for example this
this is the main 1i have one called
classes and so classes is just a data
set with it's basically just a list of
associations and each of these
associations represents a single class
so these are so I should I should give a
bit of background first not not too much
but basically this this data comes from
a comes from a recordings of an online
school so these are there there for
example there's some things that you
might not expect from a normal school so
for example if i look at the 16th class
we can maybe get a better look so for
example we have stuff like messages
because there's a there's actually a
text chat so people can can write things
during the class so that you wouldn't
probably probably won't have it in
normal school but it's it's useful for
analysis and so on because it's all of
course all the information is textual
and so on so but the I guess what I'm
saying is that some aspects of this are
sort of a bit more systematized or a bit
different from a normal school of course
but okay so so we can look at for
example this is the 16th class so if we
want to say just look at all the
messages in the 16th class we could just
say 16 comma
messages and so we can see then this is
the data set of of all the messages in
the 16th class i'll probably get to why
these some of these times are negative
in a minute if it's if it's bugging
anybody but um so let's let's try doing
something simple here so we can try we
can try let's say let's say we want to
look at you know who's who's talking the
most in this class we want to see so
these are all fake names by the way
these are all the names are consistent
but they're not the actual names they're
random names they they could
coincidentally be the actual name of the
person but they're probably not so let's
see let's let's uh so we can we can take
a look at a sort of which which people
write more messages or more words or
whatever so let's let's start with just
you know maybe who writes the most
messages that could be questioned canal
so we can we could say something
messages coma all common name right so
that should just get us all the names
for all the messages there we go there
they're just a bunch of names there and
then of course we could also just we
could say there's a function counts for
those who don't know it's I think it's a
version 10 function so but so basically
what this will do is it it'll tally up
all of the the uses of you know say
Hannah and William and so on so we can
see it how many messages each of these
people sent so that's sort of
interesting so we can see how many
messages these people sent and we can
also try doing something like maybe we
could we can make this into a histogram
so you can see I mean when I apply this
histogram here the point is that are
actually I could apply it here as well
the point is that I want to I'm
basically applying this function at the
basically at the second level of the
structure and so if i run that you can
see okay we didn't have that many
messages so this isn't terribly
interesting so now but there is
definitely a you know an obvious trend
or i guess from your respective it goes
like this so let's let's try maybe we
can try and get something with a bit a
bit high resolution here so i have a
another data set called messages which
is all the messages you can see this
says it is forty-three thousand rows so
we could try saying something like this
of all comma name
and then we could say something like
counts and then make histogram from that
okay and that that's maybe a bit bit
more interesting but all right let's
let's maybe move on a bit here so I
guess the point is though is with
something like this you're basically
you're applying the function histogram
at the second level so it's and it'll do
that after it gets the messages now the
other thing about data set which can be
sort of weird sometimes although it's
it's sort of necessary for something
like data set is that it doesn't always
run things and exactly the order you
think it will and by that I don't mean
that it's it's it's like
non-deterministic but but it it it sort
of has heuristics for figuring out
heuristics that you can you understand
they're not terribly complicated for
figuring out what order to run things in
so for example let's see if I if I have
a data set like this one here let's say
I want to get let's do this so let's say
I want to first I want to select all of
the ones all of the rows where the where
the a value in that row is odd okay so i
could say selective hash a selective odd
q of hash a right okay then they're all
the rows where a is odd and then let's
say for each of those rows I want to get
be oops there we are but now there's
something interesting about this which
is that if we look at just if we just
say D of all comma B you can see there's
there's no information about the a so
how would we possibly select all the A's
so then you'd say okay well then it's
running to select first and then it's
and then it's getting the bees and that
is what it's doing but then if i did
something like d of all comma B but then
maybe instead of all we wrote let's see
what will be a function could do here we
could say something like I think odd q
well that right to that that that was
that was listed below over the whole
thing otherwise
I did it slightly wrong Ellen with
headless okay well so I'm basically the
point is that this you can see it ran
after it got all the bees so there's
sort of a the order in which it runs
things depends on what the function is
and again it is it is there are rules
for this and they're not terribly
complicated but and and without it you
run to all sorts of horrible problems
because for example with this odd Q here
for example if I said counts right
counts is a bit less interesting because
there's only one of each but the point
is you can see the counts is run after
it gets the B or after it gets all the
bees as opposed to before like when i
ran the Select and again to have it to
have it run them the same order would
mean that one of these situations
wouldn't work or you'd have to contort a
bit to make it work so it is useful that
it runs in orders like this but all
right so that's I guess continue on to
some some more complicated stuff so
these are sort of the very basics of of
data set so we can try which I may be
looking at something something maybe a
bit more a bit more interesting with
this data so let's let's look back at
this classes here so let's try let's try
this let's see if well okay so we can
try seeing like maybe be what is the
distribution of the messages say the
message is per minute in these different
classes so what what you know do do most
of these classes have you know similar
messages per minute or some much more
talkative in that respect or something
much less talkative and so on so so we
can start just with this class here so
with 16 so we'd say 16 comma and then we
should say messages and then if we just
want to get the number of messages we
could just say / star or write compose
like okay so then there's there's the
number of messages in that class but now
I also want to have so then I want to
basically divide this by the duration of
the class so how might I do that so one
way I could do this is I could write
something like this so i could give it a
function here i give it a pure function
and the pure function could just be
something like hash messages or length
of has
half and half excuse me length of hash
messages which is the same as what we
just wrote down here and maybe / hash
full duration which is the duration of
the class basically and that will get us
reasonable result and I could say
something all there and they're there
they are for all the classes I can say
something like histogram and then
there's the distribution of the of the
messages per per minute in all the
classes so that's one way of doing it
now the other way of doing it which
might in this instance seem maybe not as
not as beautiful is is it's like this
although I I promise you that in other
cases it is significantly more beautiful
i'll get to that so we could also if i
have a data set like let me go back to
my very simple data set here so if i
have my dataset d and i say d of say two
and then comma and i give it two
functions in a list it'll apply each of
those functions to the whole thing and
return it in a list so you can see it's
it's applying it's applying f to this
thing and that's applying g to this
thing and then the point is this is
consistent with the way that part works
and the way that you can ask for
multiple parts in that with part or with
the data set you can ask for say two and
then ask for both a you can do something
like this be right so this these two are
consistent in the sense that if we think
about indices and keys as basically
being functions that get an index to get
a key then then it makes sense that we
can also give functions here and that it
will apply each of them to the gist of
the foal the full data that we're
looking at so what we can do in this
case is we don't just want the messages
the number of messages we also want to
know the duration so I can say something
like like this we can ask for the
messages and we can also ask for full
duration and so then that should return
them both in a list and so then we can
do something just
this whole list here this is just sort
of 11 sort of query in itself as sort of
a self-contained thing so just like with
these other functions and these other
indices where we can compose stuff onto
them we can also compose something on to
end of this so I could think of post
something like well we could just say a
cash part 1 / hash part 2 and there we
go and so then I could say all there and
then histogram there and you can see
these do the same thing bring it all so
if we wanted to maybe this is a bit
cleaner instead of saying this this is
the same as saying apply of hash 1 /
hash two which is in fact the same as
just saying apply divide so we could
also write it like that and that works
as well just because all those functions
are exactly equivalent or basically
exactly equivalent as long as you put
the right things in so now one of the
cool things also by data set is that a
lot of these queries you can sort of as
long as the the structure that they're
applying to is is the same you can move
them around in interesting ways so for
example right now I've been playing
around with this stay set classes right
which is just a list of all these
classes but i also have a day set called
courses and what courses is just classes
but organized by by them the course
because they're there I've data from
four different courses here so what we
could do we've built up this query right
that's sort of that given given all
these classes it will make this
distribution of the messages per per
minute so all I really need to do is I
can actually just say courses of say 1
comma this and so this will apply that
to just the first course and then the
neat thing is I can also say all come of
that and then there's just and then
there the distributions for all of the
courses so I guess it's it's neat in
that you can you can sort of build up
these queries and so on and apply them
very broadly and you can move them
around and and that way you can set of
as long as you have consistent data
structures you can use queries in sort
of somewhat creative ways so let's see
um let's maybe get to slightly more
everyone here because I think I'm sort
of running a bit out of time not quite
but getting there so let's see so let's
say that we want to look at so let's
everyone look at this so given giving
classes right we have we have microphone
data as well so so people have to press
a button and they come on microphone and
then they can talk and they can press a
button they come off microphone so if I
say 16 kalma microphone we can see what
that data looks like okay so we can see
that it has a name and then it has a
duration that they were all microphone
and so on so let's do this let's see
maybe what what let's see maybe what the
the how how how talkative people are on
microphone versus how or how talkative
classes on microphone was how talk today
aren't text rats and the basic question
is if if in a class people are talking a
lot on microphone is in a large fraction
of the time somebody's on microphone
does that also mean that people are
talking a lot in text chat or doesn't
mean that people aren't talking about
much in text chat because they're in
fact talking on on microphone or what
does that mean so so we can we can we
can look at this so for example let's
first just write something to get the
duration of time that somebody talked
I'll microphone in a class s'okay right
here we just have all the microphone
recorder all the the instances of
somebody coming up a microphone in a
class so I can just take this and then
we can say all comma duration right I'm
just going to get everything in this
column here and there we are it's down
here and I could maybe replace the total
and then there we go there's just the
total duration of how long people are
talking all microphone for that whole
class I'm so 35.5 94 minutes now we also
similarly to before we want to divide
this by the full duration of the class
so I say similarly before and that we
were we were sort of getting this and
then getting some property and getting
the duration and dividing them so let's
see so now to do this though what we
basically why do you let let's take this
second approach here because this is
where the second approach really becomes
much cleaner so what we want to do is we
want to get both this property and we
also want to get the the full duration
or
or actually in this case we actually
want to get this this other property
which is the recording duration and
there's there's sort of a subtle
difference which I don't want to get
into right here but now there's sort of
a problem here because you can see that
this it might just have to try and apply
microphone in total and duration
separately and there's nothing really
grouping them together to say that these
three are are one kind of query and that
this is another query so what we can
actually do is we can use a function
called query which will or group those
all together now the thing about query
this is also very consistent because
query is basically it's sort of like the
data set function in the sense that if I
have a list like this and let's say we
are let's say we take our took our
datasets remember this data set and L
are both they both represent the same
data one is just a list of associations
and the others a data set so what we can
do is let's let's do something with our
data set that maybe we could do with our
list okay actually this example right
here that we wrote earlier this is
something that we cannot do with just
part with our list it won't work in fact
I can I can try l of two comma after
coma G it will give me an error it says
that the expression F and G there's not
indices or keys there's there's nothing
I can do with it so let's see so what we
can do basically query if I if I take
whoops oh no I peered have broken it
okay let's see if I can okay let's see
if we can get everything back oh ok I
can we can we can continue with this
though let's see I can try and I can try
and we didn't have too much that was
reserved depending on there so we can
probably sort of get back a bit but I'm
all right so we can try let's let's
let's see so we were what we were just
hadn't out don't ok I won't forget I
don't forget this time let's see ok so
we I can try and get back to let's see
we had a we had for a class we had the
total time on microphone so class and
microphone
then all the duration so we can then say
that and so what we just wrote as I had
that list and I wanted to divide that by
recording duration so basically that
what I was just saying a moment to go so
L part so this doesn't work right but
then this this does work so how might we
try and do this to a list if it's not a
day if it's just a list how might
replies and the answers use query so if
i say query of to FG like that this
doesn't really do anything by itself but
this is it's sort of query is only an
operator form so basically i can apply
this to l and it will do the same thing
they would do to l if it were a data set
or if we queried this a data set so
really in doing this it's actually very
consistent because it's applying this as
a function just like it might apply some
other function and and you can see that
query is just a function it's not some
magical rapper thing it's actually just
a function that will you know query this
thing in a similar way to data set so if
i run this there we are so then there
here's the total time on microphone and
the recording duration so then i can do
what we did above where we said apply of
divide and we can see the ratio there ok
so this is the fraction of time that
people are talking during the class so
if i say say all there we can see it
hopefully there we go there's for all
the classes so i could maybe say
histogram instead of all to try and see
the distribution of of what fraction of
time ok there we go so that that isn't
terribly interesting because it seems
that it's close to one in the sense that
people are talking pretty much all the
time so now i guess what we can say is
well 11 guess I might have is that in
fact it's basically teachers talking a
good chunk at the time so what we might
want to do is you might want to try and
remove all the teachers from this data
because we don't care you know if a
teacher is talking is rambling on for 30
minutes or something we don't want to
really include that in this year because
at least in this particular
visualization we might only be worrying
about how talkative students are because
it's sort of a given that
you know somebody we talking on
microphone at least most of the time so
I think I said have to wrap up here but
we can very quickly look at I guess one
of the one of the be sort of final final
features of data set which is there's a
let's say I want to take syd say the
16th class and let's say I want to her
and then say let's just take the the
microphone so i have this list here
teachers and this is the list these are
the anonymized names of all the teachers
so you can see this teacher sophia is
presumably the one teaching this class
and you can see that she she appears a
number of times and talks a fair amount
so we want to we don't care about women
sophia talks we don't account that and
you can see she also talks for a fair
amount of time which it does so we want
to delete all those so i can say is i
can wear for this microphone i can just
say something like select of and then
let's see we could just write something
like freak you of teachers comma name so
basically what this is going to do is
going to say okay for each of these
things select the ones where the name
attribute is not inside of teachers
write the name key so that there we go
so now we can see that got rid of all
the teachers so okay great but now we
want to apply this to all of or we want
it applies to more than just microphone
we want to apply this to a few different
things you want to apply this to let me
just get a single class here two
messages and camera and statuses and
microphone and so on but we don't want
to apply to things like full duration or
course so you could probably write some
some horrendous pure function that does
this but in fact there's a there's a
nicer way with with data set and that is
you can actually have a list like this
just a list of rules where you say say
messages arrow and then you can give it
a function and or apply this function
only two messages and we'll leave
everything else alone so this is kind of
neat and so now I could I can sort of
selectively now I think I think what's
going wrong here is I'm pressing some
key stroke which is which is breaking it
I don't think it's actually something
I'm running but I guess this is sort of
fate because it's it's about to be three
so